yeah
[Music]
it's that time again the PlayStation
Plus essential games have been announced
for December 2022. I'm here to break
them down and let you know a few details
if you're not too sure about these games
you can grab all of the following from
Tuesday December the 6th let's do this
Mass Effect legendary edition brings
together the original Mass Effect
Trilogy into one package they first
landed on the PlayStation 3 over a
decade ago and now this legendary
version updates many aspects of the
renowned RPG series for the PlayStation
4. Mass effect's most celebrated element
at its core is choice and consequence
playing as Commander Shepard we are
constantly given dialogue decisions as
the story unfolds what's quite amazing
about this is that decisions in the
first game affect events in the second
game which then Cascade into the third
they may not be the deepest of choices
it's usually good or bad light or dark
binary options so don't expect too much
Nuance but something you do now will
affect something in 30 hours time oh and
my guy Shepard loves to the romance
humans and Aliens alike combat is all
about cover shooting with a variety of
weapons from ARS to shotguns with the
kicker being superhuman abilities to
call on to turn battles in your favor if
you love games with a huge story and
branching dialogue trees play Mass
Effect legendary edition it's rated 8.5
out of 10. next biomutant a game about
life after the end of the world where
animals have mutated and most have
mastered high-level Kung Fu and
military-grade weaponry set in a vast
open world we create our own character
and slowly learn about rivaling tribes
and the sacred Tree of Life essentially
we must choose to either defeat or unite
those tribes there are vastly different
ways to build our own character from
their core stats to the weapons they
choose and then the over-the-top extra
abilities like summoning mushrooms to
fight by your side or if that's too
weird unlock slow motion or levitation
abilities instead the open world is
filled with vastly different biomes all
of which have unique minions to wage war
against and some need different
approaches to each fight and even by the
end of the game about 18 hours later
you'll still encounter brand new enemies
you've never seen before there are at
least four world-eater bosses to
encounter who want to consume that tree
of life and it's your choice to fight to
stop them or let them do it reviews are
all over the place for biomutant from
high eights out of 10 To Mediocre sixes
will you try it and finally a brand new
game coming on the day and date of
release Divine knockout they describe
themselves as a small brawl free-for-all
in which tiny gods do battle it's a
platform fighter in which knocking your
opponent off the edge is the key to
Victory but it's also 3D unlike the
games that inspired it as Divine
Knockouts grows so will its cast of gods
and mythical beings Japanese myth is
represented through characters like
izanarme the goddess of the underworld
nor Smith has Emir and more characters
are being revealed daily until release
and we've been assured button bashing
will never lead to Victory using the
Right Moves at the right time and
monitoring cooldowns is the intended
approach waiting for your false
percentage bar to race high enough to
allow you to yate them from existence
Divine knockout could become an esport
and you can jump in from day one and
stay ahead of the skill curve so that's
our games for December 2022 what you're
playing this month I'm very tempted to
go back to biomutant my ninja hamster
with a toilet brush is calling me I'm
Adam you're awesome I'll see you next
time
[Music]
thank you